[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
una patria es alguien que no es
considerado como nacional por ningún
estado No es ciudadano no pertenece a
ningún país y por lo tanto no goza de
pleno derecho algunas personas nacen
apátridas y para otros esta condición
llega por distintas causas en este
programa revisaremos dos casos en
República Dominicana lo que comenzó como
la negativa para registrar a los recién
nacidos terminó en la desnacionalización
de miles de personas la mayoría de
padres haitianos una decisión única en
América que dejó en condición de a
Patricia al menos
135.000 ácidos dominicanos pero de
ascendencia extranjera más en el
siguiente informe
en este campo de República Dominicana
trabajadores recolectan caña de azúcar
aquí trabaja Andrés un hombre de 22 años
que a los 12 perdió su nacionalidad
nació en este país pero un fallo le
quitó este derecho solo por ser hijo de
padres extranjeros
y yo quieren que yo tenga la cédula que
diga
que ellos quieren que yo tengo que diga
extranjero
como quien dice que yo nací allá
y así no no se vale en 2012 el tribunal
constitucional establecido que solo se
considerarían como nacionales aquellas
personas nacidas en territorio
dominicano de padres nacionales o
residentes con papeles un fallo
retroactivo que aplicó a todas las
personas nacidas entre 1929 y 2010 y que
dejó a miles en un limbo legal no
dominicanos no son de aquí ni de allá y
que en el país actualmente no hay ningún
procedimiento que garantice este derecho
una decisión que trajo innumerables
consecuencias para los que dejaron de
ser dominicanos y pasaron a ser
apátridas entre ellas el riesgo de ser
deportados
estamos aquí no vamos a ninguna parte
porque ni siquiera conocemos y
argumentan el creol Entonces es una
realidad que afecta muchísimo sin
nacionalidad miles de personas carecen
de derechos no pueden trabajar de forma
legal y tampoco acceder a servicios de
salud o Educación para personas como
María no hay explicación para su
condición yo nací aquí en República
Dominicana
el estado
entiende que yo nací en Haití por ser
hija de migrante entonces en todos los
documentos te ponen nacionalidad
haitiana y migrante Y por esa razón o
sea que hay una discriminación si se
puede decir así sin documentos de
identidad tales como cédulas carnets
electorales o pasaportes de estas
personas están privadas de sus derechos
básicos un actuar de las autoridades
dominicanas que la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
califica de arbitraria discriminatoria y
desproporcionada
Sudán es otro de los países donde
cientos de personas luchan por
pertenecer la patria llegó por la
decisión histórica de la separación
entre el sur y el norte y aunque la
nación africana Avanza en sus leyes de
nacionalidad sigue teniendo a este como
un tema pendiente
cuando Sudán del sur se separó de Sudán
en 2011 miles de personas quedaron sin
nacionalidad al más es uno de los que no
son considerados ciudadanos en ninguno
de los dos países
no pertenecemos allá y tampoco
pertenecemos aquí debido a la separación
nos convertimos en personas sin
identidad país de origen o documentos
Ese es mi caso en este momento
la separación histórica dejó adultos y
niños en condición de apatria algunos
Perdieron su nacionalidad al ser hijos
de un padre de ascendencia sudanesa y de
otro con antepasados Sur sudaneses
ahora tus opciones son que te dediques a
trabajos secundarios como levantar
ladrillos o vender bolsas u otros
trabajos en los que te podría atrapar la
policía las mujeres sirven en los
hogares Y las que no pueden trabajar
allí lo hacen en bares cuando los
atrapan tienen que Cancelar enormes
multas que no pueden pagar el gobierno
quiere mantenerlos en las cárceles y no
pueden ir a ningún otro lado que no
tienen un país de origen además la
legislación en Sudán no le permite a las
madres transmitir de forma automática la
ciudadanía a sus hijos lo que aumentó
aún más esta condición organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos trabajan para guiar a
estas personas en la búsqueda de
documentos hemos logrado asegurar la
identificación nacional para unas 5000
personas de muy diversos orígenes aquí
en jartum artún es diferente de otras
provincias porque la ley sobre la
identidad estipula que se debe
Establecer un origen de una persona en
algunos casos las personas que terminan
aquí han perdido el contacto con su
origen Hay personas cuya madre es del
sur mientras que su padre es del Norte
para algunos es al revés hay personas
que son consideradas sin origen en
absoluto sentencias en Casos específicos
han permitido que varias personas y en
ciudadanía logren obtener sus papeles y
pertenezcan a su país
el número exacto de personas apátridas
no es Claro pero se estima que son
millones pensemos por un momento y si no
perteneciéramos a nuestro país de
nacimiento esa es la realidad de muchos
en el mundo y el dato de migración de la
semana
en un 96% cayeron las cifras de los
arrestos de migrantes irregulares en la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos Durante
los dos primeros meses de 2023 según el
departamento de seguridad nacional es el
nivel más bajo de detenciones desde 2021
hasta aquí migrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]